c'est satisfaisant comme contrôle je
vous conseille juste à me faire la
déclaration de distributeur automatique
examen de passage réussi pour Fabien
Puaud ce matin son distributeur
automatique de lait cru a été contrôlé
avec succès par la direction
départementale de la protection des
populations dans le cadre de l'opération
alimentation vacances les services
vétérinaires et la répression des
fraudes sont venus vérifier le respect
des conditions d'hygiène la température
du lait mais aussi la présence des
affichages réglementaires sur la machine
on a choisi aujourd'hui de faire le
contrôle de notre premier distributeur
de lait cru parce que le lait cru sent
le diabolisé c'est quand même un produit
sensible pour lequel il y a une
nécessité absolue d'avoir une bonne
maîtrise de la chaîne du froid depuis la
production jusqu'à la distribution c'est
un peu une particularité de nos
contrôles de cet été qui seront sinon
plutôt classiquement tournés vers la
restauration commerciale la distribution
mais aussi la restauration sociale et
les centres aérés les camps de vacances
et cette machine n'a pas été choisie par
hasard installer depuis pour moi sur le
parking d'un supermarché Azay-le-Rideau
elle est la première de son genre dans
la région et pour le producteur les
contrôles réguliers sont plutôt
bénéfiques le consommateur il sait qu'il
y a des contrôles donc il sait que je
dois être vigilant ça peut être bien
finalement rassuré donc il consomme moi
derrière je sais que j'ai des contrôles
donc je vous ai toujours nickel et puis
tout marche dans le meilleur des mondes
si on est irréprochable sur les
nettoyages si on surveille bien la
chaîne du froid bon il y a pas de souci
j'ai envie de dire les consommateurs ne
semblent pas s'inquiéter d'éventuelles
risques la machine distribue d'ailleurs
près de 100 litres de lait cru par jour
ça fait une semaine que je suis en
vacances à Alizée rideau et j'adore le
lait frais donc en général j'achète du
lait frais et là j'ai dû lait cru donc
c'est encore mieux je pense que si c'est
vendu comme ça c'est que c'est contrôlé
et voilà j'ai confiance et madame n'a
pas à s'inquiéter rien de particulier à
signaler pour se distributeur de lait
mais les contrôles des services de la
préfecture vont continuer jusqu'à fin
août pour traquer les irrégularités et
gare aux contrevenants car les sanctions
peuvent aller jusqu'à la fermeture
d'établissements